using dna matching brazil's federal
police identified the mortal remains of
british journalist don phillips he was
traveling with indigenous expert bruno
pereira when both men were killed
indigenous leader beto marubo told us
his people need time to mourn the loss
of two men who defended their cause
he says the union of the indigenous
people of the jawadi valley will
continue patrolling the reservation
working to stop illegal fishermen and
poachers
it's a question of survival we live in
an area which is home to the largest
number of uncontacted indigenous tribes
in the world they don't go to the local
market to buy food they depend on
fishing to keep their families alive
pereira and phillips were found 10 days
after they went missing when the local
fisherman amarillo dacosta confessed to
their killing he led police to a burial
site in the rain forest more than three
kilometers from the river where both men
were ambushed
it was not the first time he and pereira
had met
we witnessed this encounter between him
in that costa last december
the police called the murders an
isolated act they say there's no proof
they were commissioned by someone else
says he believes illegal fishing is
directly linked to money laundering from
drunk cartels
to say this was an isolated crime is a
mockery not only for the families of
both men but for all those who have died
defending the amazon
indigenous expert sydney posuelo says
president jaye bolsonaro is responsible
for empowering people trying to
illegally exploit the amazon
never in history has there been a worse
time for brazil's amazon like now not
even during the military regime
the murder of dom phillips in bruno
pereira happened four months before
brazil's presidential elections
casting a spotlight on a remote area of
the brazilian amazon forest
the javari valley is the size of austria
and home to the world's largest number
of isolated indigenous tribes
monica enachi of al jazeera rio de
janeiro